hi there you know the last few days i've
uh been walking the dog in the forest
so i thought i'd shoot some video up
there i go in there i listen to kim
jung-ha
and uh walk there's a waterfall there's
old trees so
enjoy to make it easier for us
we have a bridge
up here
no no come here gordy don't go there
gordy
you know he loves it he loves it in the
stream boy does he love it in the stream
yeah gordy is that ever great
how great is that
notice how obedient he is when he
sees something he wants
okay
so we will head off to this uh bridge
to see where it leads
there's the sort of uh stream here
before the
water goes down the falls
to the bottom the gorge there
you know
and
lots of fallen trees and stuff
and uh we're going to continue
on our way here
there we go
i
can't resist taking a shot of these
enormous douglas fir trees here
two uh pillars
guarding the forest there's a rather
large cedar tree
and we're gonna go it's like we're
walking
walk up careful not to drop my phone on
the roots and the rocks here
yeah
and here we come to a work of art which
is a bridge which
the rails have taken advantage of some
bent
pieces of wood here
no no gordy over the bridge let's go
here
so
we crossed the bridge
a couple of big hemlocks there
and uh the other end again we have uh
natural artwork
and we will continue
here on our way
and uh again where there's a huge
another big fir tree
there and these are big trees these are
old trees
all of them well young trees and old
trees
you know uh
i'm impressed by the size of some of
these trees like here's one
that was probably because it fell over
um
it was uh
cut down
and you can see that it's uh it's quite
a large stump it's rotten now of course
must have been a magnificent tree
and uh
there we go kind of move it around here
and you know here again there's some
huge
huge trees i don't know i don't think
i'm doing justice to it i can't just
keep on
videoing
trees people are going to get bored
but it's just it is absolutely
magnificent
so i'll put my video away now
yeah so there you have it me listening
to uh kim yong-ha enjoying it
again i much prefer to listen to
interesting things even if i only
understand a bit of it
um rather than listening to silly
conversation
um
i messed up on my videoing i had it all
edited and i was about to send it you
know post it and realize that the
imovie was still in the business of
uploading it so it was all lost and i
spent a lot of time doing it so i'm i
didn't edit this one i'm sorry
that's what you get i hope you found it
at least interesting parts of it
thank you
day66